كرشك هو مصدر سعادتك هذه المقوله تنطبق
حرفيا على هؤلاء الرجال الكرش هنا ليس
للسعاده فحسب بل معيار لوسامه وجمال الرجل
فصاحبه يحظى بالاحترام في وادي اومو بجنوب
اثيوبيا الرجال يشتهدون في تربيه كروشهم
لدرجه انهم يقيمون مسابقات لاجمل واكبر
كرش ويتم الاحتفال بها سنويا ضمن حدث يسمى
كايل الفائز فيه يحظى باحترام الجميع في
القبيله وحجم الكرش ليس المعيار الوحيد اذ
يجب ان يكون مدورا مع جسم مشدود خال من
الترهلات تكبير الكرش بهذه الطريقه ليس
بالامر السهل فهو يتطلب اتباع نظام غذائي
خاص للتسمين فلعده اشهر يتغذون على حليب
الابقار ودمائها اضافه الى العسل صاحب
اكبر كرش يعتبر ملك جمال في هذه القبيله
فهل تنصحون احدا بالمشاركه